given that the capital hill riots have
been probably
he managed to beat even the election
and covid in terms of news coverage over
a short period of time
what do you think people should have
taken away from that
that there is that trump was
the they thought trump was the river but
he was the
damn they thought trump was the source
of all this kind of
um uh um all the things that they hated
and that once you get like he's in i've
used this matter before he's like the
head vampire
once you go with the head vampire all
the other vampires dissolve
and you can return to what you perceive
as normal there's not going to be a
return
um you uh the enemy class will never
have this absolute power they had before
even anywhere near it uh increasingly
people are becoming not just hostile to
them
but how do you have a conversation with
someone
who doesn't just distrust you but is
completely uninterested in anything you
have to say
i don't see how you can put that
humpty dumpty back together again and i
think that is going to be
so their only metric is silence the
opposition right
if because basically if you have two
options and then i get rid of one
by default everyone's going to go to me
well it's very hard
to silence an entire population
in a world where there's technology
entire internet based on allowing people
the opportunity
to speak and present their points of
view i don't see how it's done and it's
also
and the left historically has understood
this when you drive a population
underground
and they have nothing to lose this is
going to radicalize them
and blow up in very dangerous ways so i
have thought for a long time what i
would do
if i were you know the corporate press
to try to
reintegrate this population society and
they're basically doing
the complete opposite of what i would
advise and i'm not surprised because if
they're capable of learning
they wouldn't be the enemy class what
would you advise let's say that michael
malus gets put in charge of the media
how do you bring sure the disaffected
groups back in
i would have some sort of it would be
tough
because since i have for decades been
you know advocating for war lying to a
population
just brazenly shamelessly go to their
children it's going to be really hard to
get them back on board
but i would do things like i would take
some sort of marginal figures
and put them in some kind of ceremonial
position and pretend okay we're going to
make an effort to reintegrate
i would uh stop
trying to i would have these places
where
people could have these discussions but
try to build as many moats around them
as possible
instead of trying to silence them
completely let them talk to each other
but try to have that talking not reach
the mainstream consensus
that's going to be hard um and i would
try
stop trying to do things like if you're
sitting there talking about calls for
vengeance
and people can hear you this is really
going to give them an incentive to
strike first
right because then it becomes self
defense so all of twitter was all about
we have to persecute these people we
have to drive
josh hawley from the senate said cruz
from the senate we have to make sure
this never happens again it's like
trump's numbers went up
from in terms of the voting share from
to 2016.
so you really have a problem if for four
years
of going after someone who is not
particularly a good person or a nice
person
and he had more people voting for him
the second time around
strategically whatever approach you had
did not work
because it did even though he did lose
the election it did not
decrease the number of people who are
comfortable
going in that ballot box and for
whatever reason flicking that switch on
his behalf
is that not the maddest thing that the
media legacy media the left
everybody threw everything that they had
at that election kitchen sink went the
cat went the baby and the bathwater
and only just scraped through
a democratic victory yeah and they lost
uh a huge a significant number of seats
in the house
uh joe biden is the last time this the
incoming president didn't have the
senate he has a 51-50 but you know this
is marginal
was richard nixon so that is not a
governing consensus in the house it's
something like
219 to 212. uh these are
i mean and because it's you know here in
the states
each party is basically coalitions of
different groups
219 democrats is not as cohesive and
coherent as people think because you're
going to have different wings and
they're going to have different
perspectives and
it's going to be very very hard to get
that majority through especially in the
senate where one person and you're done
and every senator of course represents
different states and has different egos
so it is um amazing and
the the articles were already written if
there had been any metric
other than losing of course where trump
kind of went down
trumpism has been repudiated the
american people come to their senses
they were just champing at the bit and
yes biden won
and they tried to put that over but it
fell completely on deaf ears
and again i don't know what they can do
to get people listening to them
um again naval ravikant on rogan
said this quote and he didn't cite where
it's from but it's the best thing that
i've heard around this
he said the left won the culture war now
they're just driving around shooting the
survivors
yeah uh i don't know that they won the
culture war they
created culture historically yeah the
bright just didn't bother getting
involved
right and the thing is there's an
enormous asymmetry between right and
left
because when there's left-wing like
cultural violence
it's rioting but when you have
right-wing cultural violence it gets
really ugly really really fast because
they're not playing
they're playing for keeps and it's it's
quick and it's very brutal
so i am desperately hoping
it doesn't reach that point and i don't
see any mechanisms of it slowing down
that's precisely what i've said for the
last few months this tit for tap
mechanism
i do a thing to you you do it back to me
a little bit more i do it back to you a
little bit more
and it just escalates and what what have
you got left
you there's only two ways that things
happen it can either be dictatorial top
down
or it can be emergent bottom up the
culture's not slowing down we've got
frictionless communication which permits
everyone to go from brain
to fingertip or mouth to internet world
with basically absolutely no
restrictions at all
that on its own accounts for an awful
lot of why we're seeing more vitriol
online like we're not built to have
our thoughts be broadcast to the entire
world like you shouldn't do it think
about
200 years ago you'd get a quill out a
piece of paper
and maybe like a pigeon or a raven or
something like that and you would send
it to the local battlements like
if you're gonna say something you better
make sure that it actually is meaningful
you can't just like toilet tweet
something that ends up going viral and
getting you in loads of trouble
yeah is this about when you guys burn
down the white house because we haven't
forgotten about that
i didn't know that russia had a had a
white house
yeah it's a crystal palace i think yeah
yeah it is yeah